I'd like to thank the organizers for
inviting you to this conference has been
wonderful and what I'm going to talk
about today is some ongoing work that I
have with my postdoc glory Steve assume
he's sitting over there and and the the
motivation for it is that we have whole
genome sequence polymorphism data from
all the great ape species except
mountain gorillas and we are in general
interested in using that data to
understand something about how fine
scale on broad scale recombination rates
change over time and that's not what I
want to talk about though because
although we've had that data for two
years there's been some some problems in
in our data analysis and and that's
partly what I'm going to talk about is
just sort of our difficulties in
actually being able to detect these
recombination hotspots so first a little
biological background so so we're we're
going to be dealing with recombination
which is a fundamental biological
process at least in diploid in meiosis
you know we have we have pairs of
homologous chromosomes and recombination
is a process that generally speaking
produces mosaic descendant chromosomes
from these pair of homologous
chromosomes and there are different
models for how that happens the standard
one is is one where you have a double
strand break in one chromosome and
there's some kind of strand migration
and that junction there are moves around
a bit and then it gets resolved and it
can get resolved at least in the
standard model in two different ways one
that's that's generally termed a
crossover which involves sort of the
reciprocal transport of a large stretch
of DNA so you can see this
chromosome has a large bunch of red over
here or it could involve something that
we turn a gene conversion which is sort
of a non-reciprocal transfer of a small
amount of DNA from one homologous
chromosome to another so we actually
don't model it exactly but the standard
way of modeling it just involves sort of
ignore it happen and assuming that
crossovers are simple crossovers without
associated gene conversion and a
separate gene conversion event and I'll
just say that is background because
actually I'm not going to talk about
gene conversion at all I'm going to
assume for the moment at least that
we're dealing with recombination just as
these crossovers okay and so there there
are a lot of reasons why we might be
interested in recomendacion some of the
standard ones are over very long periods
of time it's thought that recombination
is important for the maintenance of sex
and it improves the efficacy of natural
selection in a more mechanistic sense it
seems like it's necessary for proper
segregation of chromosomes and meiosis
and in the human genetics world
recombination is important because it's
the prime determinant of the patterns of
linkage disequilibrium that we expect to
observe and the structure sorry the
structure of genetic variation across a
genome that may become a little less
important as as human genetics moves
towards sequencing studies as opposed to
you know step based Association studies
but at least for now understanding
something about the patterns and linkage
disequilibrium is has applications both
in evolutionary and human genetics so so
there are different ways that we have of
estimating recombination rates and this
is kind of I'd say analogous to what
what Molly talked about yesterday
dealing with mutation rates it there are
direct ways of measuring recombination
rates that involve looking at pedigree
or sperm typing studies and these these
methods can provide estimates of
recombination in specific individuals in
very recent generations and the other
approach is is sort of an indirect way
and it's based on having two linkage
disequilibrium and you can think of this
as a method that that really is
averaging over lots of individuals over
evolutionary time scales so one to two
million years over both sexes and many
many generations and we generally
quantify that that indirect estimate of
recombination using this compound
parameter row which is four times the
effective population size sense a
recombination rate and so I mean it's
it's this compound parameter because
actually the LD patterns cannot be used
to estimate either the actual
recombination rate of the population
size individually okay so I think you
probably all know what linkage
disequilibrium is but I'll just sort of
put up this basic cartoon to remind
myself and you that that linkage
disequilibrium is just some way of
quantifying that the non-random
Association of alleles at different
sites so here the cartoon has each each
row consists of like a two-site
haplotype in a different chromosome so
you can think of a you know in this
example low linkage disequilibrium is
equivalent to cases where you have no
association between alleles at the first
side or the second sight hi linkage
disequilibrium means you have some kind
of correlation here they're completely
correlated that if you have a a allele
the first sight you always have a see at
the second and and so that the basic
thought is that in general the higher
your recombination rate the lower the
level of linkage disequilibrium that you
observe and and conversely the less
recombination you have in general the
higher the level of linkage
disequilibrium the you serve there's
there's a lot of variability in that
though and that's what makes things
somewhat challenging the other
challenging thing is that LD at least as
its defined here deals with pairs of
sites and and we're interested in in
recombination across the whole genome
and and that rate may may vary in an
arbitrarily complex manner okay so so
what we do know at least in humans
recombination rates do vary across
regions of the genome they vary between
males and females systematically and
even within individuals of the same
gender there are systematic differences
in recombination rates further in in
humans we know that and this has been
touched upon by by previous speakers
recombination rates are not uniform so
they vary and they vary in sort of a
specific way we're actually most
recombination events happen in a very
small fraction of the sequence okay and
it's it's generally thought that that
the two different classes of methods for
estimating recombination rates are
generally concordant so how to rebased
methods versus sperm typing versus
linkage disequilibrium based methods
generally give the same answer so here's
here's a an early study by like Gil and
colleagues where they looked in the MHC
region estimated recombination using
using patterns and linkage
disequilibrium and that's in red and
they compared it with estimates of
recombination from sperm typing which
are in blue and you know even though the
the y-axis is on a log logs on a log
scale you can squint your eyes and and
they line up pretty well okay so much
better than some of us thought they
would but they actually do line up but i
will say that when you look at the scale
here we're dealing with
several orders of magnitude difference
in recombination rate and this is not
normal for the whole genome so there are
actually only a few regions where you
expect this sort of thousandfold
difference in a recombination it's it's
more typically let's say 10 or 20 or 50
fold differences between background
recombination rates and hotspots okay so
um so another study that involved
several of the audience members here
looked at recombination rate variation
in chimpanzees using patterns in linkage
disequilibrium and and they concluded
that that chimpanzees have recombination
hot spots but in different locations
from human hotspots and how they did
this as they they had a way of
estimating the locations of different
hot spots and they looked at the the
estimate of Rho the scale of
recombination rate at so in panel a here
they have they have superimposed the
locations of many chimp hotspots and
looked at the estimate of recombination
rate in the ornithologist regions in
humans and you can see that those lines
here are flat so so that locations where
there are chimp hotspots do not seem to
have elevated recombination rate
estimates in humans and conversely here
are the locations of estimated hotspots
in humans and there does not seem to be
any elevated recombination rate estimate
in chimpanzees at those locations okay
so that's what we think we know and
maybe I'll also try to clarify that that
there are there are one set of methods
out there for estimating recombination
rates across large regions and Gill was
a pioneer in this units done some work
in this too but those those methods in
general do not quantify the uncertainty
in their estimates so if your particular
interest well as mine is right now for
identifying
those specific regions where
recombination rates are high that we
call these recombination hotspots you
need a sort of a separate methodology
for force for identifying them in some
kind of statistical or quantitative
framework okay so there are several
methods out there for detecting these
hot spots these are the main ones they
all in practice they actually all
involve some kind of approximation to to
likelihood so so we might know what we
want to do in theory to estimate
recombination rates under a full
likelihood model but those are in
practice actually not feasible
computationally feasible and I use
computationally feasible in a pretty
loose sense in that um it turns out like
actually only one of these methods can
estimate hot spots and what across a
whole genome and in a reasonable amount
of time and reasonable in this case
means a hundred years of computational
time okay so we're not talking I mean so
if you're just working on your desktop
computer you're out of luck so these are
as of now extremely computationally
intensive and and partly because of that
they haven't been well tested so then
the next fastest of these so there's a
composite likelihood version of inferno
that Bruce Ranallo develops that we
estimate would take maybe 15 times
longer like 1500 years of compute
computing time so that's um not feasible
now maybe feasible in a few years okay
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
sort of the basic structure of the
method that people use this LD hot and
for background it's based on a composite
likelihood approach that was developed
by Dick Hudson published in 2001 where
where the idea is reasonably simple so
here's sort of a representation of some
sequence data each
each line again is a haplotype each
column is a different variable situs
snip and and the idea is that if we
wanted to estimate the so that you know
in general the goal might be to take a
data set this whole data set and
estimate the likelihood of observing
that data as a function of an underlying
recombination or even a single raid or
multiple rates or whatever and so that
turns out to be extremely difficult to
do computationally and so the clintons
idea was to break up your data set into
smaller regions where the problem is a
little easier and in particular you can
break it up into pairs of sites and so
there there's there are ways of
calculating the the likelihood function
for a particular you know set of data of
haplotypes like this pretty much now you
can calculate it exactly four pairs of
sites as a function of the recombination
rate and so so Hudson's approach is to
take not just one pair but every single
parasites and and former composite
likelihood by just multiplying the
likelihoods of each pair of sites and
under this composite likelihood then you
can you can maximize the composite
likelihood as a function of of the
underlying recombination rate that's the
basic idea
yeah so so his approach was to assume
that the recombination rate is constant
across base pairs and so you're looking
you need the exact locations too because
you're assuming so you're estimating
over a rate per base pair and so then
each pair of sites has a different
distance and so then you know if you're
estimating your rate per base barrick it
corresponds to a different genetic
distance between each pair of sites yes
so in so this is assuming you have full
sequence data essentially okay so here's
here's sort of a one potential
implementation of LD hot that was used
to analyze the chimpanzee data uh and
the the basic idea is you you take your
whole genome you take sort of a sliding
window approach and so they used a 200
kb size window and they wanted to ask is
there a recombination hot spot in the
center of that 200 kb window so they
constructed a composite likelihood using
this the same hudson like approach under
a model where there's a background
recombination rate that's constant and a
putative hot spot elevated hot spot rate
in the central to kb they calculated the
life likelihood ratio test statistic
comparing that maximum likelihood with
with a comparable one under a model with
no recombination rate variation and then
they estimated the significance I mean
since you're dealing with composite
likelihood they had to estimate the
significance of anything observed by
simulation so they ran a bunch of
simulations to sort of get a p-value
attached with whether there seemed to be
you know a hotspot in a particular
location some filtering steps down at
the bottom and then they shift over
there
ol window 1kb and and do the same thing
again so you can think that you know
they're breaking up their genome into
you know millions of these 200 kb
windows doing a simple kind of analysis
estimating p value and and moving on to
the next one so so actually it's it's
step 3 here that takes all the time okay
so so calculating the likelihood ratio
test statistic is is not that long um
but they to estimate the significance of
it they were running many many
simulations and doing the same kind of
analysis and that's that's what takes up
all the time okay so one of people done
and so maybe I'm wrong that I I think
I'm only aware of three studies that
what I would sort of view a systematic
that looked for hot spots across the
whole genome and those studies included
humans chimpanzees in arabidopsis and
all three studies used used LD hot you
know there's some study of hot spots
across the dog genome but it's based on
pretty low coverage snip data low
density snip data there's one in
drosophila that that unit and colleagues
did um correct me if I'm wrong but my
understanding was you just looked at
specific regions for hot spots and did
not actually survey the whole genome
hopefully I I'm not speaking on that
front okay so so our general question is
well how good is LD hot at detecting
true recombination hot spots and there's
some challenge to determining this
because LD hot is is not actually
publicly available and it's three
instances of use all use different
methodology so it's not clear to what
extent those are different from each
other and if you actually wanted to
compare different methods you're still
stuck with the problem that is very
computationally intense
so as I said more than 100 years of CPU
time okay so so we started by trying to
implement LD hot and we did it in a way
similar to what simon did many years ago
um and we modified it slightly at least
24 for the sort of running the null
simulations for estimating significance
values we ran simulations and we store
the results into some very large table
and and use them to sort of estimate
significance for all potential hot spot
locations across the genome
simultaneously and you can I mean I
guess roughly speaking I think the
previous approach used like a parametric
bootstrap approach where for each
particular region they're running
simulations based on estimated values um
and we're we're essentially taking a
flat prior where we or a uniform prior
we're assuming you know we run
simulations assuming drawing mutation
and recombination rates from some
uniform distribution and hoping that
that covers the whole range of what we
actually are going to observe in data we
can that the point of this is that then
we can we can run at once store some
huge amount of simulations and reuse
them and however we want to and so then
it gives us this the speed up so that we
can actually see how well the method is
doing okay so that's the basic thought I
mean the methodology does differ a
little bit we looked at the the region's
identified as hot spots in the chip
study um and calculated sort of the
median p value that we observe there
compared with the median p value 41 kb
away or 2 kb away or whatever um i don't
know whether to be happy with with this
result or not but at least in general we
find a dip in the p value where we're
supposed to but our estimate of the
median p values
actually higher than point 01 so we're
not actually recovering the same thing
that they get but at least it shows that
we're doing at least something that's
vaguely similar you start with regions
world you have
for for this so these are the executives
these are exactly the locations I see
this are the exact the exact locations
and as close as we could get to the
exact data set that was analyzed it
Adams actually not sure which version it
was so did you try Adams implementation
it's not publicly available it's not
privately available it's not available
so the answer is no um uh I have no
reason to believe what happened did it's
wrong I'm just saying we made a couple
different decisions about how to how to
do things that speeded it up that
obviously can change things a little bit
okay so so then we try to run some
simulations that you can think of them
as roughly appropriate for great use um
so we started with 30 haploid sequences
because we have 15 lowland gorillas that
we wanted to analyze and we simulated
smallish regions 300kb regions that had
a single hot spot in the center that was
had an elevated rate that range from 10
times 100 times the background rate we
assumed a background rate of pointers or
14 base pair for both the recombination
rate mutation rate we've run simulations
with other values um they don't actually
make that much of a difference uh and uh
so to make the analysis sort of
comparable instead of choosing a single
p value and and doing some kind of
filtering we chose a different strategy
where we would choose the p value so
that the false positive rate was roughly
the same across simulations under
different parameter values and we we set
that as some arbitrary you know half a
percent sure
the background and you might think you
want to pick them again given the hot
spot a moocher of the genome so are you
claiming that it if I made it five or 10
times lower it wouldn't make a
difference it makes very little
difference actually shockingly little I
don't I don't quite understand that I've
run them as low as whatever rate Bruce
Ranallo uses which i think is six times
ten to the minus five per base pair it
makes a slight difference um I have some
thought I mean I can talk to you offline
about this I have some thoughts as to
why that might be okay so so that
actually brings up an important point
these simulations are meant to be okay
so simulations that that have been done
before took an optimistic case okay so
they said okay well let's look at the
MHC region and assume that's normal and
we assume a very low background rate in
a very very high hot spot rate and
looked at power for detecting a hot spot
where the you know the hot spot rate is
like 700 times the background rate um
that's thoughts of normal um we took the
opposite strategy at least at the start
where this is a somewhat more
pessimistic view so you can think of the
scale background right what Molly saying
is essentially a scaled background or
accommodation for much of the genome
will be less than pointers or one per
base pair that's true we've done some
simulations for half of this and one
type of that as well um okay uh we also
employed a minor allele frequency cutoff
for point 05 there's there's some reason
for doing that that I'll talk about
later okay so here's the power um to
detect a 10-fold hotspot 2450 fold
100-fold so you can think of this for
regions of the genome they're not not
optimally and the power is not optimal
it ranges from six percent to maybe
fifteen percent and so when you when you
look at when you look at what's going on
one thing that becomes clear is that LD
hot has difficulty determining what I
would say this specific location of a
hot spot so it may sort of think that
there's a hot spot somewhere but it
can't figure out exactly where it is and
and I think qualitatively that's due to
the nature of the composite like we have
used so you can think of it it's it's
it's looking at all pairs of sites
within a 200 kb window and you're trying
to find those sites that have some
information about just the central to kb
and the surrounding area so you have a
question I think biologically is on the
order of a few hundred base pairs to a
couple kb and length so 2k being might
be on the large side um but it's a
specific here your meeting with
educating I I guess what i mean by
specific it has difficulty determining
where the hotspot is to within 10 kb
let's say ok and the reason why it can't
figure that out it's because it's
looking over 200 kb window and most of
the pairs of sites that are used for
this composite likelihood are totally
uninformative about that so they may be
both on one side for example or they may
be 150 kb apart and it's very hard to
figure out where hotspots going to be in
the center because you're only looking
at you know you only have information
about you know two sites that are very
far apart ok um and so your power it
wasn't about whether you take kasbah
anywhere it was about whether you detect
it in the right spot so ok yes so so
this power is for for the locations that
actually were hot in in the simulated
data what proportion of them were
identified as hot spots in the
simulations what was that it was the
we knew if there was any hot spot or
whether you ate dessert this is odd how
does the find the power the power is
defined as the probability of of a
particular base pair that's actually a
hotspot being called as a hotspot okay
so so if you identify a hotspot that
includes half of the true location then
that half it counts as fifty percent
power and if there's some part of your
hotspot identified that's somewhere else
then that counts it in towards your
false positive rate your call it is at
the resolution of a thousand base pairs
yes yeah so I mean in this case you know
either you're calling it so there's a
2tb hot spot you can call it exactly you
can call it halfway or you can not call
it at all so if in practice so if you're
worried about the dilution effect of
picking up to larger window I guess I
don't you things that immediately spring
to mind one is if you've tried waiting
the different pairs differently and the
second is what if you start with regions
that are identified as hot using elven
hat how much does that help since that
has narrower resolution okay um yes we
have worked on waiting things I'll talk
about that in the next slide oh and I'll
get to LD hat as well if I haven't
answered your question okay maybe you
can remind me oh yes
understand the issue resolution but we
kind of when we did simulations of
apparel all those years ago I think we
counted as a success if we had evidence
of sale and he valued lesson 101 at the
center and then the resolution is you i
Jes we thought was saying we were just
where as in you know we knew it we had
anyone sit for 5 ppm yeah well I mean
you know I think obviously your power
calculations were different because you
had sniffed data and that was in part
the reason why you took 200 kb windows
you couldn't take a 10 kb window because
you and your data so I i think you know
I've tried to talk mostly about the the
chimp data because it's comparable in
the sense that it's its whole genome
data there's very dense sniffs oh but in
that particular case because you know
the specific method they used as well
they're having this problem and so they
deal with it by cutting out regions that
they if the region looks like a hot spot
that's too large they throw it out okay
so that that's that's the Auton at all
approach as you probably know since
you're an author and it and my only
point is just you know if your goal is
to say okay well are you getting a low p
value where you're supposed to that yeah
you do a lot better but but that's not
the whole question the question is if
you're if you're trying to actually
analyze data and identify hotspots using
some criteria can you do a good job of
that
some hot region and how much is it about
knowing exactly where it is I think I
agree that the second one's harder okay
do we do always use LD ha ok so let me
always have to use LD how to do the best
of that but we still don't do ok
terribly well hopefully I'll get it that
in in a couple slides here's one example
so let's take let's say you do the same
analysis but you change your window size
ok and so now instead of a 200 kb window
you take a hundred katie liddo or 50 kb
window or 20 kb window this is how your
power changes and and i guess the point
I'm trying to make is it's it shouldn't
be too surprising that your power
increases when you have a smaller window
size because you're sort of it and this
implicitly is is a very simple weighting
scheme it says if your snips are too far
apart the weight is 0 otherwise the
weight is one we played with other
weights um and uh you know for it so ok
so even though we've speeded these
things up you know these simulations are
still like you know it takes us a while
we only have like five hundred examples
for each of these cases it's kind of
slow we can increase our power slightly
but I don't know if I believe it yeah
good condition on having exactly one hot
spot or could you have many of you can
have many hot spots you can have it many
a hospital ok yeah when you're analyzing
the data you know dust relations in
these simulations so that Rueter or even
at 5r you yes yes ok so one point is
smaller window sizes make more sense if
you have sequence data um you know
another thing that can speed things up
is to throw out low frequency variants
so we looked at well what happens you
throw out like all rare variants rare in
this case defined as fiber centerless
learn allele frequency I don't know
there's not much difference um so in
general there's there's this is good not
just because it speeds things up but
because those rare variants are exactly
the class
variants that have the highest error
rate and in sequencing studies so so
it's thought that there's going to be a
substantial false negative rate where
there are a lot of Singleton's that are
being missed and in addition you know
the ones that are called or somewhat
arbitrary the amount of evidence for
them being there is not always very
strong if you if you don't have
extremely hard coverage data ok so we've
run a couple other simulations also not
surprisingly if you look at different
sample sizes your power generally
increases when your sample size
increases and so I think the the point
is well power is pretty low when you
only have 20 chromosomes so that would
be the equivalent of 10 individuals but
just moving it from 10 to like 18 makes
a huge difference it really increases
your power a lot we've run other
simulations but I mean okay yeah okay I
think my sense is when you're that low
like any any amount that you increase is
great I mean you know percentage-wise
you're increasing the power by let's say
thirty to thirty percent that's pretty
good I don't know when you're starting
pretty low like Theresa I'll take it um
you know I mean so we're running a
little more simulations I mean I think
my basic thought without knowing yet is
that essentially things work well in
humans because you can keep on
extrapolating this curve until you deal
with like 60 individuals or something
that is you know and I'm 120 it's gonna
be a lot better than it is with just 10
um okay so so we looked we started
looking briefly whether a different
method would would do better um and I
started with something that was
extremely easy to implement so a method
of convenience not for any particular
true biological or statistical reason
so we looked at a sort of replacing the
Hudson that the underlying Hudson
composite like livid with a summary
likelihood approach where where you sort
of take data and you you calculate some
summary statistics on it in this case
the number of 78 incites the number of
distinct haplotypes in the minimum
number of inferred recombination events
and then using a simulation-based
likelihood scheme where you estimate the
likelihood of observed data as a
function of the recombination rate and a
similar kind of likelihood ratio test
comparing a central 2kb window with some
kind of region on the side and that the
specific details don't matter because we
just chose arbitrary ones at least at
the start and at least in some cases you
can increase your power significantly
well significantly as in its greater
than zero increase now importantly maybe
not but but significantly yes we also
looked at this this inferno which which
is the closest thing to an
implementation that sort of incorporates
this full likelihood that we think we
might want to do on the implementation
that's available has low power and
extremely low false positive rate so
it's good for something it's like if it
calls a hot spot you're pretty sure it's
a hot spot um but it's not going to call
very many of them um so there's a chance
if if if you tinker with the code you
might be able to get some improvement
but but I'll still have a caveat that
you know to infer recombination rates
and hot spots across a whole genome
would take 1,500 years so that part
hasn't changed give me your computation
time and I'm gonna like this but you
really didn't compute our C code yes um
we've done that and I'm not showing
though
I'll just leave it at that you can you
can interpret whatever you want from
them um another depressing thing is that
these simulations were idealized um and
so there are other sources of error that
we are not accountable so that would
include so once you go out of dealing
with humans you have assembly errors you
have genotyping errors because you're
generally not dealing with extremely
high coverage data and you don't have
have a typeface it's it has a version
that's full likelihood presumably not
the one that's giving a worse answer
than the version we used is it is sort
of a composite likelihood implementation
where you do full likelihood on small
regions does it do worse fall I mean
we've we've played with the I mean the
powers of function of like some
arbitrary parameter that I can't change
in their program and it influences both
the false positive rate in the power so
it actually may have if you if you
tinkered with the parameters so that I
had the same false positive rate it may
have a higher power I suspect it does
but um I haven't actually been able to
get them to help me take the lip the
code and I haven't done it myself okay
so here so as I was saying this is this
is the scenario that will never actually
have because we don't have that kind of
data okay so so if you think that those
are low well that's under the ideal
scenario oh here we have sort of sources
of error that we need to deal with and
i'll talk about how to deal with a
couple of them so we're going to deal
with genotyping areas just by throwing
out rare sites so so this is sort of
coming back to why we were hoping that
you could just eliminate sites that have
a minor allele frequency less than five
percent um and then we we took the
strategy that LD hot did of of well I
mean that the pan that paper did by
taking
the genotype data and computationally
phasing it and then using LD hot on
those you know on those inferred
haplotypes here's the power that you get
um you know kind of looks like the last
one except that the y axis has changed
so all the powers are lower oh you know
so in the previous version you know
these green bars went from like sixteen
percent up to 40 something percent and
now they're like 52 twenty-something
percent so roughly speaking on when you
don't have haplotype look phase the
powers sort of have roughly ok and then
so so those simulations differed in some
way with the the actual method used in
in the Auton at all chip paper so then
we try to see well if we change sort of
the filtering steps to as closely as we
can mimic what they did to try and see
sort of what the power would be in the
false positive rate so so we took ten
individuals we computationally phase
them we assume that the true situation
was you have this high background rate
although the results are similar for
other background rates and a mixture of
tenfold 2450 fold hotspots and we took
the two filters that they used one is
eliminating hot spots that were too
large and the other is sort of
cross-referencing with LD hat so this is
what you were talking about and
eliminating hot spots identified by LD
hot that don't have a peak recombination
rate of at least point 05 / base pair
using LD hat LD hat being that the
general method for estimating rates LD
hot the the hot spot one okay so this is
what LD hat estimates look like um it's
partly because your sample size is ten
individuals of partly because you have
too computationally phase it this is
what you know is not great these are
where the actual hot spots are in the
simulated
and escalate your eyes you can kind of
see I don't know there's sort of peaks
in general over there but there are lots
of other peaks that show up um sort of
so our simulations sort of found a
density hotspots similar to what what
the pan map people did and we estimate
at least under these assumptions that
the power is roughly eight percent and
the false discovery rate is very high
over 80% on and even if we take a lower
background rate you get a false
discovery rate that's that's always well
over fifty percent so so what that means
I don't know this is why we've had some
trouble analyzing data if you if you go
back to to the a panel this figure um so
if you chose random regions throughout
the genome you would get the same thing
and the reason why is because the the
process by which you choose them is that
you you eliminate regions that don't
have a peak rate that's at least you
know point zero zero five for base pair
okay so you hear you're requiring that
regions are about five if you just
choose random ones you'll get a peek
here and a flat line for humans okay
what we don't know is whether there's
actually a very small bump on this red
line here now you can squint your eyes
and say I don't know does it kind of
move up a little bit the reason why
that's interesting is okay we're sure
that that the vast majority of hotspots
are not shared between humans and chimps
and there's many reasons for thinking
that but I think it's still an open
question of whether there are some hot
spots shared between humans and chimps
and the problem is is that this red line
here okay first off is going to be a
mixture of of true hotspots and you know
oh well I mean I guess what I would say
is when your false discovery rate is
very high then what you don't know is
okay maybe I'll phrase this a different
way this red line here is a mixture of
potentially true hotspots and
potentially many many more true cold
spots um and so finding out whether
let's say a few percent of hot spots are
shared between species is actually
pretty difficult okay so that's about
all I have to say I'll be right there's
a much higher positive rating ship that
they're awesome results that suggest
that these lots of the places of the
accommodation protected ship by the
world like the DC signal uh-huh if you
said I mean like if you look at the
amalgam of the evidence so I think
giving you probably remember burden i
will but the signal for like bias
towards GC basis at site site employers
hot spots of chimp isn't so much weaker
than the from the signal the human
hospital right no i mean it is weaker
but it's Saturday Night Live Nation it
could be that it's a more effective
process on the chip lineage for example
mm-hmm and it certainly should be the
better hire positive influence with us
the question of the correlation at 100
kb scale which is already quite good
between humans and chimps and I'm trying
to figure out how the numbers that you
report give us a really good correlation
so okay so those numbers are based on LD
hat and so if you look at this well I
mean yeah it kind of looks like a mess
but it if you'd average and it looks
pretty good so um my sense is once
you're averaging over 100 kb with
Windows you do a pretty good job and
I'll penny.hope supposin hundred that's
a thing right there's one you grown
so but those correlations are based on
LD hat so that's that's a different
question how good is LD had at
estimating an average rate of 100 kb
versus how good is LD hot at identifying
a hot spot but the hot spots were
identified on the basis of Peaks an LCD
hat that's just a filtering step they're
not there they're identified as a
combination I mean the the primary
determinant is that it has a low p value
when you compare to these null
simulations I mean I I understand what
you're saying I mean in the other I mean
the other larger question is given the
LD hat Natalie hot are using the same
composite likelihood why is it that
their results don't always seem to line
up um that's a separate question but um
but anyway I think my general sense that
there are lots of different parameter
values that we don't actually know but
in general I would say that at least the
existing methods we have seemed to have
moderate or poor power to detect real
word combination hot spots at least in
species besides humans I'll when when
you help you don't have phase in your
small sample sizes I think those are the
big differences is really nice so
like how much worse is the asian that I
don't know but I assume that's pretty
photos well I mean the other thing is
that phasing gets easier when you have
more individuals so it's sort of it
compounds that it's sort of like when
you don't have enough individuals it
it's you can't face well and even if it
okay but that's exactly like few
mysteries all right but you did a lot of
these critiques also apply to the human
I don't know I would assume that the
human maps are mostly correct just
because I think that once you increase
the sample size large enough then you do
a lot better no it's it's on the list
but it turns out it's very very slow to
simulate the sample sizes that are
comfortable for human studies yes so um
yeah I mean it's sort of a background
thing that we're trying to look at
larger and larger sample sizes but it'll
take I'm this at diminishing return as
you go get snot two samples yeah yeah
this is this opportunity no I mean I
think that there's something there that
like you know input you know I still
think that the human results are
probably quite accurate but the
simulation results of may or may not
like suggest that they should be
accurate and so there could be some some
difference there that needs to be
explained and I want to try and say that
you know i I've tried there's a
difference between simulating exactly
what I think the thing that's closest to
the truth is which is not what I've done
here when simulating sort of a
deliberately somewhat pessimistic case
because well in part because previous
simulations were overly optimistic
or suggested qualitative difference in
terms of the quality of your results
performance cases and that's a very
interesting suggestion if that's true
and I don't know what your evidence for
them is you're like you're making you're
saying with larger sample sizes are face
data we do better but you have a
demonstrator that so these critiques
feel confused that's true but I mean we
get an improvement a thirty percent from
sample size 10 to 18 purposes and to
some extent good extension useful mates
so okay maybe the the more honest answer
is I don't really know I have my
suspicions we're going to try and run
some simulations that they take a long
time and so you know I have to wait a
couple months at least so I think if you
want to make your simulations more
pessimistic you could take it to account
the fact that every chimp has a
different PR dm9 area because I think
that's a much bigger issue then because
right now you're kind of you know
optimistically assuming that everybody
shares the same hotspot which is
actually probably kind of true in humans
at least in some human populations but
in chimpanzees as you as you know it's
very far from true and so then we're
actually trying to detect a mixture wats
Watson well but I would argue that that
that you're always just your ear
estimating an average anyway so so what
I would argue that there's a there's a
true population scale recombination rate
under a host of assumptions that hold
for let's say the Western chimp
population and under that can you
identify any of them that needy hotspot
so I think what you're saying is that
even with full data there may be fewer
LD based hot spots than in humans
because you know the effect of PR dm9 is
is more spread out I guess what I'm
saying is that you know your 10 full 24
30
agri hire the chimps are pushed towards
the left relative to humans yes and
yours yes currently that they have the
same lambda values of whatever you're
calling that that's true um just help
your right okay there's a lot of detail
built into the simulations and you
thought her just subsampling from the
human data to show that things fall
apart was for sale um yeah so so I mean
so to a limited extent the pan map study
did that but it's very hard to figure
out exactly how they did that I think
they they took genotypes that were
already called using imputation on a
much larger sample oh so to do it for
real you would start with raw data raw
human data and you would go through the
same process well if you want to be
totally accurate you like take the human
genome and you like screw it up some so
that it's like comparable in quality to
it so that the chip do you know and then
you go and you map the reeds under the
screwed up one and and do some snip
calling and maybe imputation and then
some phasing and then try and identify
hotspots so that would be the
appropriate thing to do and we haven't
done that yet